movies are very powerful because they
transport you to a different world and
therefore movie is really good then you
forget you're sitting in the theater
watching a screen you're in it i'm
deepak chopra and my favorite movie is
lost horizon lost horizon was a little
different because it wasn't that popular
but i had read the book so when the
movie came out i was actually watching
the movie with an eye to whether it
actually accurately represented the
feelings the emotions that were aroused
in my imagination while i was reading
the book
the movie about the infinite
possibilities in hindsight it influenced
what I do now it influenced my entire
career I have written more than 80 books
and this movie has influenced a lot of
my books because it gave me a glimpse
into the timeless mind my personal goal
is to reach a billion people and my
mission always has been to realize a
more peaceful just sustainable healthier
and happier world in other words
shangela or planet Earth this movie is a
reminder that it is our state of
consciousness that is reflected as the
world at all times i'm deepak chopra and
i love movies
you